markine
tu as déjà entendu parler d'elle non
elle a inventé l'art abstrait avant
kandinsky malevitch
elle affirmait que le monde des esprits
communiquer avec nous à travers et
j'ai préparé tous que keira avez vu
qui je suis et personal shopper ce
boulot en berne
j'ai l'impression de perdre mon temps
c'est nul et ça m'empêche de faire ce
qui m'intéresse
ça me rend malade
quand un bon jour je dois retourner dans
la maison dit oui bah si
frère est mort ici on s'est fait un
serment celui qui mouraient le premier
enverrait un signal autres insignes
comment saurez-vous si c'est ainsi
sur fois plus
et
toi aussi il faut que tu ta franchise
lewis
après la mort il n'y a rien
il est là